fresh off a break in Carson Palmer
single-season school record for passing
yards and perhaps could be the first
name out of roger goodell mouth when the
Browns were on the clock Thursday night
he Sam Donald how are you Sam I'm great
thanks for coming on I really appreciate
that lots to talk with you about what's
going through your mind right now as
draft week is finally here
Sam yeah it's a lot of excitement a lot
of nerves as well in terms of just like
not knowing at all what's gonna happen
um and but I think it's more excitement
though I'm really excited for this
moment again I mean it's a cliche but it
really is something I've dreamed of for
a long time now and I'm really just
ready to get to a team I get to meet my
teammates and all the coaches and get to
work trying to have a great season and
all that stuff so I'm really excited and
again I think it's just exciting to be a
part of a team again which I'm really
looking forward to well currently your
current team right now is I guess team
Jordan Palmer in a way and we had Jordan
here a couple of days ago and you have
been working out with a couple of
Allen's Kyle Allen and most prominently
as well Josh Allen how of you and Josh
handled
I guess hearing back and forth with mock
drafts and conversations for weeks that
it's going to be either one of you named
on Thursday night first yeah first of
all I mean I heard the comments you made
about the Hat so we might we might talk
about that later
we got a pin in that first Sam you got
yeah yeah we'll get to that Sam you got
it but yeah I mean just living with Josh
you know just I mean that house was
awesome living with Josh and Kyle was
amazing and there was never you know it
was never awkward with me and Josh we
know that that's out of our control you
know who picks you know who first and
all that type of stuff so I know that
whatever happens I'll be excited for him
and he's going to be excited for me so
we've become really close over the past
few months and it's it's developed into
a really really cool relationship
something that I'm looking forward to
carrying on but yeah having it's never
awkward because we know that that's out
of our control
how is easy
roommate I mean it was a roommate at the
combine and you've been hanging out for
them how how has he been Josh walk me
through that scouting report with Josh
Sam yeah I mean he's amazing he's a
really good guy clean for the most part
I think he would say he would say that
I'm clean too
for the most part maybe he would say I'm
sloppy I could also say that he's sloppy
but um I think it's just so weird guys
so I think that's just kind of how we
live life but uh no they were cool with
each other I mean he's a great roommate
he's someone that you know you love
living with and he's really funny you
know crack jokes every now and then so
it's just really fun to live with them
and I had a great time this uh this
offseason training with them and getting
ready for the combine and drop well and
in terms of his cleaning up after
himself were there any accuracy issues
Sam were there any issues in accuracy
around let's say the hamper or anything
like that yeah nothing nothing crazy I
mean every now and then you know you
would have a wrapper and missed the
trashcan that wasn't you know it wasn't
too bad no accuracy issues in terms of
throwing Andreea way but okay or
throwing laundry in the in the hamper
but definitely was trash every now and
then red flag Sam red flag all day long
so in terms of your visits I mean who
gave you the the in your gut like
walking away that I think this is the
spot I think this is the place that
that's going to draft me but gut when
you walked out of the building which one
gave me that gut feeling the most Sam
yeah I really got a good from all all
the teams I visited it was a really
great visit I had great vibes you know
even leaving everywhere so I couldn't
tell you that I couldn't tell you which
visit was better because they're all
great I love meeting with all the
coaches it was cool you know being with
the Giants and the Jets because the
players were there it was really cool to
interact with them and the Browns
coaches were amazing there for an office
is amazing as well so it was just every
visit I went to every place that I went
to this offseason was amazing when you
went
to visit the Giants Ystad players where
there was Eli one of them yeah you I was
there I didn't get to talk to him I saw
him from a distance working out Mia in
the weight room but I didn't get to talk
to him at all he was busy pretty much
the whole day so how ready do you think
you are for the NFL team drafts you you
think you could go by week one Sam yeah
I mean if that's the plan if that's what
they want to do it I'll definitely be
ready by some week one you know
obviously a few preseason games would be
under my belt by then and but you know I
think I'm gonna star in whatever role
that the team or the coaches want me to
be in that's what I did at SC I thought
I was a really good scouting quarterback
and the defense ready to play whatever
team they're playing that week and I'm
just gonna you know star in my role you
know as some coaches like to say I'm
just gonna do my job and that's that's
really you know I'm just I'm just going
to be there to you know do whatever the
coaches tell me to do and do it at the
highest level few more minutes but Sam
darn 'old USC quarterback soon-to-be
National Football League quarterback
care of Kay Jewelers here on the Rich
Eisen show what's the strangest question
you were asked throughout this entire
process Sam I don't know I thought I
mean I hate to come back to but I think
your conversation with Jordan about the
Hat and what what type of person I am
because of that hat you know it's just
that's a different conversation but you
know obviously don't know what question
was the hardest but that was definitely
an interesting conversation and
something I've never heard on the radio
before well Sam let's get to it just so
you understand that question was set up
just in case you said something that you
were asked the comm bar in the process
was the strangest question to get to the
elephant in the room Sam as you know I'm
a follicly channel I'm a follicly
challenged individual so as so as my
buddy Chris Brockman who's here on the
set we couldn't help but notice when you
were thrown at your pro day it was
raining you put a hat on and I'm
wondering if that was to protect the
elite quarterback hair or what the
process was and your answer is crucial
because this is a red flag potentially
Sam
yeah it was because so I have free long
hair right now and if it's raining that
hair gets in my face if it rains so the
reason I wore the Hat was pretty much
just to keep the you know keep the hair
out of my face it wasn't to protect my
eyelashes I know that's what Jordan said
I think that was just I think that was a
shot in the dark okay because he doesn't
have you know he doesn't have the hair
that I do but you know it's that was for
him to to decide to say and kind of it
was it is what it is but yeah it was
definitely just to keep my hair out of
my face which is you know it can be
pretty annoying when you're trying to
throw throw a ball to a receiver okay so
it wasn't like a pomade situation that
that that wouldn't work that wouldn't go
how about wait a minute how about the
Baker Mayfield sort of Cobra Kai
you know bandana what about that yeah
you don't do that Sandra I could rock
one of those too I'd have to you know
I'd have to call Baker and see if he can
lend me one of those but yeah I don't I
don't have one of those in my possession
I think I could just you know rip off
part of my shirt and use that but okay
yeah I don't know I don't think that
would be that big of an issue getting
that but I
I prefer the Hat to be honest with you
okay Sam that's Justin yet another
evaluation as you but the evaluations
about to end which I'm sure you're very
very excited about what are you doing on
behalf of K jewelers Sam what do you got
for them yeah so the partnership with
Kay Jewelers has been amazing so far you
know my mom and dad have you know raised
me to be the man I am today the you know
just they've been amazing throughout my
whole life they've raised my sister to
be the woman she is today and sometimes
there's you know there's no real words
to be able to describe that love so I
just you know I got her a necklace from
Kay Jewelers and it's beautiful she's
gonna she's going to be wearing it at
the giraffe's and it's it's you know
Mother's Day is a couple weeks away so
you know I decided to surprise her today
with with the necklace and it's really
easy to all you have to go to is Kay
calm which is the website and then any
Kay jewelers store so
really easy gift for your mom especially
you know if if you know you love her the
way I do it's amazing it's an amazing
gift and she loves it and how as I
assume everybody's gonna be there what
steamed Arnold gonna be like on Thursday
night how big your it's your past your
plus one Sam plus who how many well I
mean they gave us a ton of seats this
year so we got fourteen seats in the
green room and then six in the stands
maybe some change
I'm a it depends you know who comes
through and who doesn't but so right now
it's about we're about 20 deep right now
in terms of just being at the draft and
hanging out with me before and after so
I'm really excited it's going to be a
great time no matter what happens and
I'm just really excited to get to a team
and be able to call a place home okay
well before I let you go I'm gonna ask
you here are we on rich the rich eyes
and show we play start bench cut where
we gave you three subject or three
places or three titles three options for
you to start one bench one or cut one
Sam and we did this very question with
Josh Rosen so again your answer is
immeasurable okay alright Sam has no
option but to say yes we appreciate you
doing that here we go start bench cut
with Sam darn 'old of us see where would
you want to live the most Cleveland New
York Denver start bench or cut Sam do I
have to do this right now
this is uh are you gonna opt out is what
you're gonna say again I might opt out I
don't want to be I mean I'm I have a
good feeling of what Josh might have
said I don't I don't think I want to do
that I mean I just you know I'm a few
days away I don't want to want to risk
anything you know I've come this far so
see you I don't you're reading that do
you want to ask me a different question
that would be amazing
okay here we go here we go stand Arnold
stands Arnold here we go you ready Sam
Donald start bench cut baseball cap
no cap or the Cobra Kai bandana start
bench cut start start the baseball cap
okay
bench the hair and cut the ninja Cobra
okay Anna
there you go it's okay to say Cleveland
you can say clay but it's totally fine
defense he read the defense he didn't
like what he saw and he called a timeout
he burned a timeout he's got two more in
his pocket
hey Sam great chat with you when the
drafts over come back on certainly if
you're back here in LA that's where
we're based so we'll see you soon
hopefully
all right thank you got it that Sam darn
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience